a breakfast barbecue in the middle of
what's normally a busy downtown street
now full of parked vehicles these
truckers say they've been so overrun
with donations they're feeding people in
the neighborhood too we came here
to be
respectful of the people that live in
the city but still make our cause heard
but some fed up residents feel all this
has become more occupation than protest
alan gimmel took a sandwich calling it
repayment for his lack of sleep now we
hear these horns going all night long
it's driving us crazy i haven't slept in
three days we're trying to get to campus
but all of the
bus routes to campus or close it's a
little bit intimidating coming into work
which i have to do every day
[Music]
they're in what i would call the splash
zone i feel bad for them
but
when you want to change something in
history there's always going to be some
uncomfortableness involved in that there
are fewer vehicles but it's still
complete gridlock on a number of
downtown ottawa streets like this one
and a number of businesses and amenities
remain closed including a major downtown
mall two child care centers a
vaccination clinic and a number of
businesses
it's like we're being held hostage down
here the metropolitan brasserie shut its
doors after it became clear delivery
drivers couldn't get through we've heard
the message and
now you're hurting our businesses and we
really would just ask that they leave
peacefully and let our city get back to
business because you're really just
ruining people
the noise pollution itself the constant
honking you know it seems as like a
like a real scare tactic the protest
prompted ellie charters to start a
grassroots walking buddy program for
downtown residents operating through
twitter dms it doesn't seem to me as
though any concrete actions to make
people feel
safe is happening on the part of the
police or the mayor many want police to
start ticketing and towing but that's
not happening yet and an end game isn't
clear we're not going anywhere we've
lost our jobs a lot of us
some of us have lost our houses
some of us will lose our houses with
some residents calling for more action
there were no updates from police today
one is scheduled for wednesday there is
now a tip line to report hate incidents
or anything criminal related to these
protests but police haven't said how
many calls they've yet received donna
all right abigail beeman in ottawa